the story
combined with the object you really do
get a little bit of a piece of art you
know they're not priceless but they're
irreplaceable even if you were to get
the exact same type of teddy bear from
the same manufacturer it's not the same
things it's not the one that's been
through those same cuddles it hasn't had
that same you know love put into it
through these telling of these stories
it actually becomes quite apparent to
how connected we all really are we go
through these things where we feel like
we're the loneliest we've ever been no
one's ever felt this way before it turns
out everyone has this is a very shared
experience
if there's a candidate for a boulevard
of broken dreams
Hollywood boulevards the wide
you